oh hey crazy say didn't see you there as
you can see I'm baking some cookies you
know this reminds me of something where
was I all right cookies if we tried to
guess how they were invented we'd
imagine some genius of food realizing
exactly what to do or at the very least
someone with a lot of time and money
just randomly mixing ingredients and
setting oven temperatures until
something works when in reality this
beautiful creation came to be through an
insanely slow process first there was
just bread and crackers then in the 7th
century CE II Persia discovered sugar
cane which quickly spread across the
Middle East and eventually Europe then
came cakes from the Old Norse word caca
then came something kind of like a
cookie or kokia in dutch meaning little
cakes which will probably originally
used to test oven temperature so bakers
didn't waste a whole cake
it wasn't until 1930 that some random
person in Massachusetts ran out of nuts
and on a whim mixed in crumbled bits of
chocolate instead the point is no single
person can be credited for the invention
of the cookie it took a series of
accidents and thousands of people
spending many centuries and several
continents discovery is almost never
sudden it takes time but humans have
trouble with time I'm not talking about
time dilation at high speeds or near
black holes those are actual physical
changes to the passage of time and most
of us could never hope to experience
them in any noticeable way know what I'm
talking about is our perception of time
which is deeply dependent on our biology
and psychology you know brain processing
sensory signals amounts of sleep
emotional states drug use even age let's
start with the smaller issues we've
talked about whether or not plunk time
is a single moment in time but that's
still a matter of debate for a human a
psychological moment is about one tenth
of a second or a hundred milliseconds on
average it can vary a little throughout
the day or from day to day but there's
you way to test it with a ruler have
someone hold a ruler in your hand like
this without warning you or psyching you
out they release the ruler the ruler
will fall before you have a chance to
catch it however far that is well tell
you how long it was falling that's what
we call your reaction time for an
average human and an average day that's
about 1/5 of a second or 200
milliseconds I thought you said it was a
hundred milliseconds that's because your
reaction time is two moments one for
your brain to realize something is
happening and another for your brain to
do something about it
so half your reaction time is one
psychological moment for you in that
hundred milliseconds your brain can play
around with timing a little so the
causality makes sense like lining up
what you hear and you feel with what you
see after that you have a limited
attention span transient attention is
your subconscious attention on something
that suddenly changed somewhere in your
field of view it only lasts a few
seconds selectively sustained attention
is when you consciously choose to focus
on a task it can last anywhere from 5 to
20 minutes after that you have to choose
to refocus on the task the point is were
hardwired to deal well with seconds
minutes hours and days for months and
years we need to rely on our memory and
that can be a little tricky if we learn
something and it doesn't continue to be
useful or to seem important your brains
not gonna hold on to it it's part of why
classes have assignments it's why
advertising gets shoved in your face
over and over and over politicians use
it hoping you'll forget their
indiscretions and their opponents do
everything they can to remind you of
them even when we do remember events we
don't always accurately remember how
long ago they occurred
our memories pretty good if you're a
hunter-gatherer trying to avoid dangers
like tigers or poisonous plants but it
makes us essentially blind to things
that can take decades or more like
global warming anything that seems to
last longer than a human lifespan we
call permanence like magnets or trees or
even cities when it comes to the really
long-term stuff like history we have to
tell stories we want there to be a
narrative for there to be purpose
when someone tells you the cookie came
into existence through a series of
accidents it's perfectly natural to
stand there in disbelief
it's called confirmation bias you reject
the new information because it doesn't
fit into your pre-existing experience a
single accident doesn't appear to do
much we can't see its effects but a
bunch of accidents happening over
centuries well that brought us the
cookie if a few centuries of accidents
can make a cookie then it shouldn't be
surprising to find a hundred million
years of evolutionary accidents turned a
small mammal into a human it shouldn't
be that surprising somewhere in a vast
universe billions of years of accidents
made a solar system where we happen to
be able to live these timescales are
completely incomprehensible for the
human brain that's why we have to rely
on physical evidence and the scientific
process without them we can't possibly
hope to see the whole picture huh I need
another cookie
so the next time you have a cookie maybe
think of evolution for a moment mmm
delicious delicious evolution let me
know in the comments what your favorite
type of cookie is and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
in the last video we set the record
straight on inertia
come on response time papa k pointed out
that I pronounced Aristotle wrong
apparently I put the emphasis on the
wrong syllable but if you want to get
technical
Aristotle isn't even the full name it's
been shortened over time technically
it's Aristotle e's sounds a little more
great doesn't it
I actually include the original Greek
spelling on the HD wallpaper available
as a pertinent patreon LAN like Vikings
said that without friction the car
wouldn't have gone anywhere in the first
place sure take all the fun out of it
David suggests that science isn't about
right or wrong but about creating models
this is important so we're gonna spend
some time on it whether we like it or
not the universe is mostly spectrums
it's mostly gray area anything you think
as black or white has probably been
imposed on the world by people it is
also true that a goal of science is to
create models so we can make accurate
predictions about reality which model
you choose depends on how much error
you're comfortable with the earth is
pretty flat if you're only looking at a
mile or two Newton's laws work really
well until you go really faster near a
black hole no model predicts anything
perfectly so I would agree there is no
absolute accuracy but that doesn't mean
you can't be wrong if science were only
about models and predictions it'd be
pretty boring luckily another goal of
science is to see the big picture to get
a deeper understanding correct and
accurate are two very different things
in the grand scheme there are some
absolutes the earth is not flat it is a
ball period it might not be exactly
spherical but it's definitely a ball
those absolutes might be vague but
they're still absolutes and the more
science we do the less vague those
absolutes become anyway one more thing
before we finish up more quickly
approaching 10,000 subscribers on this
chain
we're also approaching 100 videos but I
think we'll hit the subscriber count'
first what should we do to celebrate let
me know in the comments thanks for
watching
Swiper clone no swiping
Oh